hey you guys
welcome back to another flickers of fear
show for whatever reason i decided i was
gonna do the show with
mothman sitting beside me i'm sure he'll
have some contributions
later on i hope not like that'd be
really scary if he actually started
talking
but yeah so we're going back to my
beloved giallo movies for this
episode and this was one i've seen a lot
of uh this guy's other giallo movies but
this was pretty much the only jala movie
that he made that i hadn't seen
this is the 1972 film your vice is a
locked room
and only i have the key yes that is
probably the best giallo title in the
world
i will say that it's like it doesn't
really have anything to do
with what happens in the movie uh the
reason that he called it that
was because it's a reference back to the
first giallo that he directed which was
the strange vice of mrs ward this was
directed by sergio martino in case i
didn't mention that
and that was something that there was
like some kind of plot point in that
where a killer left a note to one of the
victims that said that on it
and i guess he liked that phrase so much
that he decided he was going to name a
movie that even though it doesn't really
have anything to do with what goes on in
the movie
uh the movie is has a bunch of alternate
titles as a lot of
italian movies tended to do then uh the
one that makes the most sense to me is
uh eye of the black cat i believe was
the name of it
um there was another one called excite
me which is dumb as hell i think that's
what it was called in the uk maybe
and one other title that wasn't really
all that compelling
um i had the black cat probably the
better title uh just
thematically like in terms of what uh
you know i don't like that title as much
as the actual title but it actually does
have
more to do with what's going on in the
movie because here's something that i
wasn't really aware of
before i watched this movie and then
like as i was watching it unfold i was
just kind of like
oh okay we're going that way with it
this is pretty much
it's like a giallo film sort of it's
more on the
erotic end of the joke because there's a
lot that are like that
uh you know more than the bloody gory
end there is a murderer running around
who has you know a bill hook and he's
cutting uh young ladies up
but that's kind of almost i don't say
it's like sidelined but that's like not
the main thrust of the plot
um the main thrust of the plot is more
like a weird
sado masochistic sort of like character
study of this married couple
and and then this girl that comes there
like later on
and then the second half of the movie is
pretty much a straight-up retelling
of edgar allan poe's the black cat
although a little bit
different but not really all that
different i mean as soon as because the
cat like features very very uh
prominently in this movie so once it got
to that point where they were kind of
going along those lines just like oh
okay so we're doing the black hat but i
didn't realize that uh you know what i
mean but i it's weird because i feel
like a lot of
god there's been a lot of adaptations of
the black cat and a lot of italian ones
because there was two evil eyes
that was uh george romero and dario
argento they did an adaptation in there
i think lucio folchi
uh at some point did an adaptation of it
so
this one it's it's not an exact
adaptation because there's a lot of
other
uh [ __ ] going on in the you know first
part of the movie
but pretty much the second half of the
movie is straight up the black cat
so if you've read that edgar allen poe
story or seen other
movie adaptations of it then you'll
pretty much know where it's going
that said though i liked this one
because it's
it has some standard giallo elements but
it's sort of
you know i don't know if i'd say it like
subverts them but it does something
different with it
and i actually didn't really guess where
it was going
like toward the end like i didn't really
guess who the killer was and like it
kind of surprised me a few times
as i said if you're if you're real into
like dario argento's ones were like you
know these really spectacular like gory
kills
don't be disappointed because this one
you know there's a couple
like i said a couple girls get hacked up
with a bill hook and [ __ ] like that but
it's not super
gory uh you know it's not super i mean
the the killings are very kind of
workmanlike
this is more it's more like a gothic
giallo in a way
and as i said it's kind of more
interested in
the interplay between these three
kind of terrible characters and like all
the [ __ ] that's going on around there
so basically as i said this came out in
1972 it was directed by sergio martino
who prior to this had done
a strange vice of mrs ward he also
directed all the colors of the dark
which is probably my favorite one of his
because it has like a weird
psychedelic surrealist kind of thing and
there's like some witchcraft [ __ ] going
on in there and i always like that
he also directed the case of the
scorpion's tail which is uh also pretty
great
so what we have here is we have
luigi pastilli who was in i believe he
was in the good the bad and the ugly he
was also in a
bay of blood the mario baba movie he
plays this
complete douchebag named oliviero
and he lives in this villa and he's a
writer and i guess he was a professor
too but he's sort of like
over the hill kind of washed up at this
point uh he hasn't really
written anything in a long time and he's
a little bitter about it uh
kind of an alcoholic real kind of um
kind of degenerate nobility type of
character like he has going for him so
at the very beginning of the movie
uh we're at his villa and he's having
this party and apparently
i watched another review of this where
somebody else pointed out i think it was
grumpy andrew i love him
go check out his channel but he was
talking about this movie and he said
you know not only is the second half of
this movie based on the black cat but
the first half
has a little bit of not exactly but a
little bit of a whiff of uh mask of the
red death to it just in the sense that
oliviero is just kind of this degenerate
[ __ ] face who has all these who has this
big villa and he has all these lavish
parties and he's just like a terrible
person
and uh so it has kind of that aspect to
it so at the very beginning
i guess he's having i didn't realize
this the first time i watched it but
then the second time i kind of like
uh you know it occurred to me that he's
having this big party
at the villa and i guess it's awake for
his mom
now they don't ever say this outright in
the movie
but it's implied that maybe he had some
weird incestuous [ __ ] going on with his
mom because he for sure is like super
obsessed with her
and there's a painting in the house of
her
and i think she's really dressed like
mary stewart like and she's got kind of
all the
you know royal finery on or whatever and
she's in
she's pictured there with her little
black cat
uh whose name is satan and we'll get
back to satan in a minute he's the best
character in the movie because you guys
know how much i love cats so he's having
this party
and he invited all of these hippies
from a nearby campground so they're all
kind of doing the [ __ ] you know they're
drinking taking drugs and then they
start to sing along which is
uh horrifying but i think so because i i
should explain the first time i started
watching this movie
it got like five minutes in and then it
was just like the hippie started singing
and i was like oh jesus christ
okay i can't deal with this right now
but it's like it's really funny because
you really need to stick with it because
that's just like a what the [ __ ] kind of
moment but after that it's just
like gets more normal at least normal in
the sense of like a jala movie but i was
just like why
we really didn't need hippy singing okay
but so at this party
uh we established what a [ __ ]
oliviero is because
his whole deal is that he pretty much
lives to be a shitty shitty person
to his wife irina who was played by
uh anita strinberg who she was in like a
bunch of
uh jl movies i think she's swedish i
believe and she was also a model
so he he does this really gross [ __ ]
where he's just kind of like you know
demeaning her
and stuff and then he goes around to all
the other party-goers
and because she doesn't want to drink
and he's like dumping
all of their you know half drunk wine
and backwash into this [ __ ] bowl
and then he like forces her to drink it
and then as if he wasn't enough of a
dick then he proceeds to
molest their black maid and say all kind
of like racist [ __ ] so it's just kind of
like
he he's just a special special fella so
that kind of sets
that whole thing up so at the beginning
what we establish
is that this guy's a [ __ ] he's abusing
his poor wife
he has a weird thing going on with his
mom who is now dead
and his mom has bequeathed him this cat
named satan
and the wife irena really really cannot
stand this cat and apparently the
feeling is mutual i guess the cat
doesn't really like her all that much
either
uh and i will warn you that i mean
obviously they didn't do anything to
harm
an actual cat at least as far as i know
but
i mean if you've read the story the
edgar allan poe story the black cat you
know like some pretty terrible [ __ ]
happens to cats in it and it happens in
this movie too
so just kind of know that going in
because the cat in this is like super
adorable he's all like fluffy and black
and he has like big gold eyes
super super cute even though he's named
satan i i wouldn't hurt him you know so
at the beginning you kind of have your
standard
giallo sort of thing now the first
victim of the
killer and this happens like pretty
early in the movie is this girl named
fausta
and fausta used to be a student of
olivieros when he was a teacher and i
guess they started bonkin
when he was her teacher and then they
kind of carried on the affair i guess
the wife kind of knows about it because
it seems like oliviero kind of gets off
on his wife knowing that he's [ __ ]
around on her although
there's an implication later on too that
he might be impotent but i'm not really
sure
you know what that's all about i don't
know it was like an implication that
just kind of occurred to me
a couple things that some of the
characters said like led me to believe
that
so fausta he's supposed to go meet her
um you know they're gonna go [ __ ] or
whatever
and then she ends up brutally murdered
with a bill hook
at the site where she was supposed to
meet him coincidentally
oliviero was not home that night
so the cops who i guess it was sort of
like an open secret that he was bonking
her she worked at a bookstore and i
guess he like hung out there at the
bookstore too the cops come to his house
and are like hey were you home last
night and he's like yeah i was totally
here
and then his wife uh irena even though
she knows that he wasn't home
and even though she knows that he is a
horrible piece of [ __ ] who probably
just killed a girl said yeah he was
totally here so she like covers for him
so it's this whole like [ __ ] for the
first part of the movie which like i
said and i am gonna spoil this because
this movie is like super old it came out
in 1972.
you can watch this movie there's a
really nice arrow blu-ray release if you
want to buy it
uh you can also i believe you can watch
it on amazon prime and you can also
watch it on shutter at least in the
united states not sure about other
countries
but it's pretty i think it was kind of
hard to get for a long time but it's uh
pretty easy to get nowadays i think
and i you didn't hear it for me but i'm
pretty sure you can uh
watch it on youtube as well so i'm not
i'm not sure what the quality is
the one that i watched on shutter
because they just added it a couple uh
weeks ago they added a bunch of sergio
martino's movies
and the one i watched this actually was
not dubbed into english like a lot of
the giallo's uh were that you know got
shown in this country this was actually
uh in italian and had english subtitles
i think it was still dubbed because they
dubbed all of them as far as i could
tell
because this has uh actresses and actors
and actors from
that are not italian uh so you know like
anita strimberg is
uh swedish uh ed beage uh fenich
she's french and she was in a bunch of
uh sergio martino's movies too we'll get
to her in a minute
so there's this whole [ __ ] up dynamic
between oliviero and arena
where he's just like the worst and
she kind of starts to suspect that maybe
he's a murderer
but she seems like she's afraid to leave
so yeah so there's that whole kind of
thing going on
like a couple other people turn up dead
and it does kind of seem like he's
conveniently not home like when it
happens
so she starts to more strongly suspect
like even then their uh
their maid ends up getting killed you
know in the house
and so she's starting to suspect that
her husband is a murderer
and you would not be uh i mean you could
be forgiven for thinking that because
like i said not only is this [ __ ] but he
actually like
straight up like threatens to kill her
sometimes like it's like oh yeah
would you really believe i could cut
your throat maybe i'll start with you
and all this other stuff i'm like dude
you're really not helping your case here
i'm just saying
so that kind of goes on for the first 20
30 minutes of the movie that's more like
kind of the giallo thing and you know
that uh if you if you know anything
about giallo movies
you know that the person that they
really are setting up to be the killer
is
totally not the killer so i mean even as
much as they said olivia's like he's
just this terrible terrible person like
there's nothing redeemable about him at
all
he's never at home so they set him up so
obviously that you know that it's not
him so then
a little way into the movie we start to
mix things up a little bit oliviero's
niece
floriana invites herself to
stay at the villa with them just you
know hey i'm showing up you better come
pick me up from the train station
[ __ ] it's kind of that kind of thing
now apparently uh oliviero has not seen
her since she was a little girl
she turns up and uh man she ain't a
little girl no more
and uh she's played by ed v finnish who
at the time and even nowadays uh one of
the most beautiful
women like in any of these movies in
movies
of all time she's just like
supernaturally beautiful
like i said she was in a really lot of
uh jl movies
including several of sergio martino's
ones so she
shows up immediately oliviero even
though he is her uncle is
just like hubba hubba and uh so he's
like oh
of course you can stay here and all this
other kind of [ __ ] uh not only
is she like drop dead gorgeous but also
she's real
uh sexually liberated uh she i think she
has sex with pretty much every major
character in this cast now that i'm
thinking about it
and she's just kind of like no
complications man we're just gonna bang
it's fine
and uh olivia is like yeah i'm into that
action so it's that kind of [ __ ] going
on
i will say too and i think i mentioned
this earlier this is way way way more on
the
kind of more smutty giallo angle than
the gory
this is like straight up there's like a
lot of soft core porn
there's you know there's a lot a lot of
nudity a lot of like prolonged sex
scenes so if that's like your bag then
you'll probably be into this
kind of it's not as sleazy as it sounds
it's a little bit sleazy
but it's it's mostly tasteful but i mean
a lot of the sex scenes are obviously
gratuitous but
you know what wasn't like at this
[ __ ] era of
movie making particularly italian movie
making and i think a lot of sergio
martino did a lot of uh
this i i think it's been a while since i
saw the case of the scorpion's tale
but i remember that being like pretty
smarty too um you know it's just
bouncing boobies everywhere and you know
lesbian love scenes
hetero love scenes it's just everybody's
banging everybody and uh you know so
it's it's fun for uh
boys and girls alike but yeah so she
shows up
and she pretty much immediately the
fascinating thing about her character
other than the cat i think she's my
favorite character of this
is that you're not entirely sure what
her motives are
like when she shows up because it seems
like as soon as she gets there
she immediately starts playing husband
and wife against one another
so what she does is basically she'll be
like
sympathizing with arena it's like you
know he shouldn't treat you like that
you should do something about it and
it's like you know being and she
pretty much uh takes her to bed almost
immediately arena seems very grateful
because i guess she hasn't been getting
uh any
so she's just kind of like becomes
attached and then but she's also
kind of like flirting with olivier like
in a kind of acerbic sort of way
and then they end up banging and then
also she in some kind of random thing
which doesn't really
uh you know have anything to do with the
plot she starts
[ __ ] some like motorbike dude i think
they just wanted to put motorbikes in
the movie it's like because i don't
really think that guy figures into the
plot
that i remember like in any significant
way she's just like some other guy that
she's just like hey i'm gonna [ __ ] this
guy i guess he sort of figures into the
plot at the end but it's like i don't
know
it's it's not like a big thing it's sort
of like a little side thing so it just
goes to show how
sort of sexually liberated she is she
doesn't want to be tied down she just
wants to like bang whoever she wants to
bang but like i said
because she shows up and immediately
starts playing these two against one
another you're not entirely sure what
her deal is and for a second
for a second i thought maybe she might
be the killer but that's not how it goes
so as i said there's also a lot of [ __ ]
going on with the cat satan
the cat sort of doing naughty cat [ __ ]
like
killing a whole bunch of irena's doves
at which point arena gets really mad and
pretty much stabs out the cat's
eye so they don't show it super i mean
they do but it's like you know it's
obviously fake
good because i didn't want it to look
real and then the cat kind of runs off
and then the husband gets all pissed off
and would you do to my cat and then you
can like hear the cat kind of like
yelling in the background so like i said
if you're familiar with the edgar allan
poe story you'll kind of know where it's
going from this point
so after that it's interesting because
like i said the giallo aspect is really
only happens in the first part like a
couple people get killed
uh oliviero is kind of the main suspect
because
you know he was banging the first one
and it's like the second was their mate
and it happened in their house and they
didn't really have any other suspects
and [ __ ]
but then he goes um but then the killer
kills somebody else
this sort of this sex worker like in a
brothel
uh who didn't really have anything to do
with anybody they and somebody else
like i think the madam comes in and like
whacks that dude on the head or
something like that
and so they catch that guy so that
wasn't like who it was
but then you also see this other dude
who's wearing like a very really obvious
gray wig who's kind of like lurking
around
and you do kind of find out who that is
later on so as it turned out like i said
i am going to spoil it so if you don't
want to know like go watch it because
i'm going to tell you how it ends
because i actually really really did
like the way this ended because i
totally did not see this coming because
irena's character
who up until this point has been
just a complete and total like victim
um and you also kind of sense too like i
said that she has some kind of like
masochistic tendencies because there's a
couple of really weird scenes where like
her husband will like
[ __ ] like smack her around and like
call her this that any other thing
and then they'll have sex and she seems
like she's not into it but then
kind of also sort of into it so i was
like well maybe that's just her thing i
don't really know so
how the [ __ ] is this going so there was
that kind of whole thing too because i
was like why don't you just
leave and honestly um you know floriano
like tells her a few times it's like hey
we're on a picnic it's like he's
standing right over there by the cliff
why don't you just like poop and like
push him right off and i was just like
yeah do a girl but she doesn't
uh but that was like foreshadowing for
later so it turns out
that despite her having seemed like a
victim this whole entire time
it is actually irina who has
masterminded
this whole plot not only she reveals
uh did she kill oliviero's mom
before the events of the movie took
place
but her and the dude with the gray wig
also
started killing other girls that they
knew that olivier was banging because
they wanted him
to suffer they wanted him to be under
scrutiny by police they wanted this that
because she was saying you know you're
such a drunk now that you would
you could have killed somebody you
wouldn't even remember it so it was like
really really easy
to even like make you question yourself
like whether you had done it or not
so she's pretty much engineered this
whole entire plot from the beginning
she was the one that killed the maid she
was the one that killed all the girls
from the beginning like i said so she
could make her husband
look guilty now interestingly
what ends up happening with that is that
after she reveals this
to oliviero she kills him
and then her and floriana are like okay
well we need to like bury this
douche bag down in the cellar and so
that's what they do
but then at this point arena realizes
she's like okay well now this [ __ ] is
like has all this info on me so i'm
gonna have to like bump her off as well
so she gets the gray-haired guy and then
they set it up
so that floriana and the motorbike dude
that she's banging get into a horrible
accident and they both die horribly
then irina because she doesn't like
loose ends
um that like i said there's there was
some foreshadowing this is the beginning
the the
guy with the gray wig is just like yeah
we did all this plot and she's like yeah
wasn't that awesome it's like we just
figured everything out i got the villa i
got all the money i got all this other
kind of stuff
he's like i'm just gonna stand right
here by the edge of this cliff and she's
like boop
she just like pushes him right off so in
a way
i was kind of like everybody in this
movie was so shitty that i was almost
kind of like yeah man you go girl
just get it but as i said if you've read
the edgar allan poe story
you know she's not gonna get away with
it because what ends up happening
is that the rag and bone woman who we've
seen a couple times like walking around
in the movie saw the cruelty toward the
cat that arena had been doing she saw
her stab the cat and she reported it to
the cops
so the cops ironically come to the house
to report to
uh investigate the animal cruelty thing
and
while they are in the house the cat
starts yelling from behind the wall
where uh irena has hid the bodies not
only of her husband but also of the maid
that she killed earlier
so you know it doesn't look too good uh
having some bodies behind the wall in
the cellar i was just kind of like
saying i was like
those those aren't mine i don't know how
they got there but like i said just like
the edgar allan poe story the cat
somehow gets behind the wall where the
bodies are and yells and yells and yells
until the cops like buffs the wall down
and that's how she's found out as the
murderer so
as i said this is actually um i've seen
most of
i think i've seen most of sergio
martino's uh giant now that i'm jealous
movies now that i'm thinking about it
um this is not my favorite of them i
think that would probably be like i said
all the colors of the dark just i liked
the psychedelic uh kind of [ __ ] going on
in that one in the witchcraft
angle i liked that but this one is
actually really good really worth
watching
um everybody in it is a terrible person
but
they're terrible in really interesting
ways and i really liked
the way that they focused on the
interplay between
the three main characters and you
weren't really sure like i said what
anyone's motivations were
like i said the giallo aspect as in you
know unknown black gloved killer going
around hacking people up
it does have that aspect to it but it's
sort of like minimal
that's pretty much just in the second
part and then the the um
or the first part rather and then the
second part goes more in a gothic edgar
allen poe
direction uh where it's just you know
you find out this big reveal she was the
one that masterminded it all along
and as i said if you're into gore uh
it's probably gonna let you down because
there's really not
a lot of the kills are just very not
lame but they're just not not all that
bloody not all that gory not all that
creative
but that said um you know if you like
smut you'll really be into it too
uh the some of the shots in this are
really really cool like there's some
really interestingly uh framed
shots uh the score didn't really make
that much of an impression uh some
people like it some people hate it i
don't even
really remember what was going on in it
um as i said the first time i watched
this like the first five minutes with
the hippie party
i was just kind of like i don't know if
i'm in the mood for this right now but
that's pretty much the only time that
that bizarro [ __ ] happens like after
that it becomes sort of
a more normal type of movie again so
kind of stick it out past that
yeah i didn't really get like while the
hippie started singing and then it just
kind of went on and on and i was just
kind of like what the [ __ ] is happening
here
but it's just like just a weird like i
said what the [ __ ] moment which happens
in this yellow movie sometimes
but other than that this is a pretty
solid uh gela movie uh
not the best but not not a throwaway one
either so definitely check it out if you
like jlo movies and you haven't seen it
oh i forgot to mention this
there's a part uh kind of later on in
the movie where oliviero who's an
alcoholic writer
types the same phrase over and over
again
like in the office he goes in the office
and slams the door and then you hear
typing
and then later another character comes
in and sees like
the same phrase like typed over the
whole page
and i was thinking wait a minute this is
pre the shining this came out in 1972.
i can't one i can't remember when the
book came out but i can't even remember
if that typing [ __ ] was in the book or
if it was just in the stanley kubrick
movie
but in any case i'm pretty sure the
novel came out after 1972.
so the fact that so now i wonder if
stephen king or stanley kubrick saw that
and like were homaging it because it
happens a couple of times i can't
remember what the first
i think the first phrase that's typed
over and over again is something like
kill her and bury her in the cellar just
like typed over and over and over
and then the second time it's just says
vendetta or like revenge
uh over and over so i just thought that
was really interesting i was like huh
maybe that's where like the shining
where he got the idea from because i
i didn't even realize and i and i
haven't really seen a lot of reviewers
bring that up so i thought that was like
kind of an interesting little uh
little touch there so you know who knows
all right so
that will do it for this flickers of
fear on another italian jello classic
your vice is a locked room and only i
have the key from 1972.
uh so check it out like i said it's on
shutter i believe it's also on amazon
prime
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye